i'm never going to go back to teaching
now right
and i got really drunk with two friends
in a hotel room when the kids were all
in bed like really drunk we'd had a
bottle of tequila between the three of
us then i heard kids running around it's
so bad isn't it
her kids running around and i'm quite
good at pretending to be sober when i'm
not so i said i'll i'll go out and i'll
deal with this to my to my friend
tony
who's still a teacher
and i went out and there were these kids
all in their 90s in pajamas all giggling
and i went out what's going on here
like i'm sorry sorry sorry i said you
know you should be in your bedroom it's
absolutely disgraceful and i was doing a
beautiful job when tony
came out of my room and i don't know why
he was just in his boxer
had a really big pair of boots
don't go like this you should be
embarrassed